dans l'autre série des conférences aux
anatomies peu appliquée nous étudierons
ce soir un autre mammifère ya voici un
homme en pleine possession de ses moyens
c'est à dire innocence la semaine
dernière je vous ai ennuis en étendant
sur un sujet scabreux
la femme s'était pendu à temps les mots
namibie la semaine prochaine je vous
parlerai du lap hall
alors voici voici devant noël un bipède
un très beau très beau spécimen de
vulgariser ou masculin simplex voici sa
poitrine
et à ce propos je vais vous faire
remarquer une nuance subtile on dit un
homme a de la poitrine quand il fait de
la cellulite nord mais un drame quand on
dit elle a de la poitrine
il s'agit là d' le provocation exulte à
toi
mieux voici le vent ou abdomen le gros
intestin suivi de l'intestin grêle s'est
petit à petit de diversion nerthe
étudiants à l'insu du sujet alors le
réflexe regardez vous allez tous deux
des cinq sens la vue
voyez vous toujours louis l'ouïe
l'odorat le toucher
donnez moi votre main en voici une main
et laisse à la maison avec cette main
une petite diversion les deux étudiants
à l'insuline juge
je suis dans une réaction burlesque le
réflexe mais bon passons à la bo de 0,1
où l'affectif
on dit jeter dans la peau ouais un rôle
respiratoires surtout pour les marins à
pons dépôt
on peut les navires mais qu'est-ce que
je tiens là et bien sûr tenir motors
enfin si nous voyons oui que c'est mu
contre briller dès 2h ou si les deux
sont arrêtés l'un avait tout article et
surtout quand il s'agit vous héniart et
la médecine
nous verrons alors je vais profiter de
ses articulations pour faire une pause
de vie version à lui le real sont bio
l'ex le réflexe rien
eh bien eh ben c'est une autre
et à quoi cela sert-il à à avoir à vous
ea sexe et mais bon maintenant faisons
l'expérience unique de la naissance
supposée des premières lettres voyait ne
l'a jamais prononcé par le premier rang
causant sur la tête première vision de
la beauté du monde à première vision de
la première femme un peu sexy aux
premières explications à donner à la
première fois dès qu'apparaît la seconde
femme dans la vie du premier rompu e à
cause de ces deux femmes l'homme pleure
pour la première fois et enfin l'homme
découvre le fort à lui le vul réactions
dures laissent leur et place bien les
voyelles et et il lui restait plus qu'à
découvrir les consonnes et voyelles et
consonnes allait plus tard se réunir
pour former cette nouvelle réussite de
l'homme dans l'expression réflexe